a suspect is in custody in connection
with the stabbing deaths of Ford
University of Idaho students last month
authorities sorted through thousands of
tips and tracked Brian coburger more
than 2 000 miles away from the murder
scene to his parents home in
Pennsylvania's Pocono Mountains as Donya
Backus reports police are trying to
determine a motive for the killings
what I can tell you is we have a
individual in custody who committed
these horrible crimes after 19 000 tips
in a quadruple murder case that Drew
Nationwide attention detectives arrested
28 year old Brian Christopher coburger
coburger was arrested at his parents
Pennsylvania home the 28 year old is a
PhD criminology student at Washington
State University just a 10-minute drive
to the Idaho campus kohlberg is being
held without bail and will spend the
weekend in Pennsylvania his extradition
back to Idaho expected next week the
arrest caps nearly seven weeks of fear
and frustration for families of the four
murdered students this is the first bit
of joy that we've had in close to seven
weeks we hope that there's they've
picked they've picked the right guy and
that gives us hope and we haven't had
hope for a long time Kaylee Gonzalez
Madison mojin Zana Cardinal and Ethan
Chapin All stabbed multiple times as
they slept and inside this house near
the campus despite surveillance video
showing the victims in the hours before
they were murdered and despite thousands
of tips pouring into the Moscow police
department they appeared at least
publicly to be little movement on the
case no suspects no arrest as the grief
mounted and many students left campus
outside the house the caution tape has
finally come down
no arrest will ever bring back these
young students however
we do believe Justice will be found
through the criminal process
the district attorney who will
eventually prosecute kerberger once he's
back in Idaho says an arrest does not
mean an end to the investigation they
are still searching for tips from anyone
who knows the suspect we should know
more after the extradition hearing
Tuesday in Pennsylvania for CBS Saturday
morning Donya Backus Moscow Idaho